yes precisely our conception of religion
is very much linked to the notion of
exclusive truths are and the truth
claims and these days the way the
liberalism has basically argued that
unit you need to get rid of religion
because they cannot negotiate their
tooth claims and therefore they cannot
be part of a consensus building in the
polity this is the fundamental notion
against religion is come from this
notion of the truth claims they are
unusable and they tres to do with
somehow liberalism being more open and
that religious pluralism leads to
conflict I've been always tracking
sociologies by the fact that a digital
even Peter burger that has abandoned the
theory that modernization leads to
secularization heey still maintains the
notion that modernization leads to
religious pluralism that leads to
undermine the truth claims of each of
our religion therefore to relativism
I've always found this argument suspect
suspect because America is for the more
religious a pluralistic society in the
world and India these are the two most
religiously pluralistic and none of them
are very relativistic were very
nihilistic extremely so somehow you
could have all religions all of the in
claiming to be true and somehow all of
them being sure that their religion is a
true one but somehow accepting the truth
claims of the others so actually it is
in the context of precisely religious
homogeneity where you give no chance to
the religions of the others because by
definition you define them as simply
untruth and and so what Indian China
shall as models India of course is the
religion itself of the defines itself is
the pantheistic religion of all that can
incorporate all religions this is
however very different system from the
Chinese where you had a mother of reduce
prism work covering with the state
itself they finally at any moment what
was the Orthodox
and then whether the other religions
were tolerated who are not dependent on
the state India never had a centralized
state that they find those things it was
more a question of a common civilization
but that was I mean we know to Hinduism
as a as a system only really emerges
systems and isn't as an ism only
immersed in the 19th century and it is
said was hundreds of different types of
religious structures that they were
unified traditions and as rituals later
so yes it is true that both at least
systems have a different model of
regulation of religion by the center one
doesn't have a center that regulates
religion are like an in this respect
very similar like America doesn't have a
center that regulation region free
exercise in saina you will have a
national religion in fact the only thing
that unified and was the so-called free
teaching that sometimes were put
together Confucianism Buddhism and
Taoism but the interrelation between the
two at which point which of them was
hegemonic has changed through history
and always Christianity comes in an
undue stress the process differently but
the valid aspect of your question is
that indeed we are entering a moment a
global moment in which the kind of a
mother of Cosmos secular cosmopolitanism
that comes out of the Enlightenment is a
very Christian kind of model is going to
be to put into question by alternative
models of secular cosmopolitanism the
same way that I argue that would you
have all the global religions are
basically themselves being
particularistic and defending their
truth claims but at the same time
claiming to be global and universal full
of humanity in the same way you are
going to have competing cosmopolitanism
so when you have a western coast of
religions another because of organisms
oh no no you have Western cosmopolitan a
Chinese cosmopolitan you have Indian and
they are going to compete with one other
in different conceptions of what the
cosmos Cosmopolitan's the globe should
look like and the only thing we can say
is that is going to be much more the
Chinese the state is going to be
centered in the final it orthodoxy the
state the Chinese estate has always had
they claim to define what is Orthodox
within the country and this continues
and this is going to be probably
continue in English a very different
model